kenosha wisconsin is the place
politics won't leave alone the election
trail that's re-routed through here
has brought its two contenders in two
days
joe biden came here after donald trump's
visit on tuesday the healer
after the hardliner as he would have it
this was a community gathering after
he'd held a private meeting with the
family of jacob blake
the black man shot by police in this
city last week
he joined the private meeting by phone
he talked about how
nothing was going to defeat him
how whether he walked again or not he
was not going to give up
we talked about a psalm in my char
church father
based on the 23rd psalm may he raise you
up on eagles wings and bear you on the
breath of dawn until we
and keep you in god it's holy in the
palm of his hand that we meet again
did you come down here to create a lie
and get one of my people shots
arguments rumble on here but kenosha has
left behind the violent protest of a
week ago
how the city's story shapes the campaign
will be important in this
key state that in 2016 donald trump took
with less than one percent of the vote
whoever helped
us for us that's a godfather we assess
the impact of the political messaging
starting here the second hand car
dealership
that lost two and a half million dollars
overnight
they have to understand that we're
feeding
20 families we have 20 employees
eight of them already told us that hey
i don't think we're gonna get back on
our feet if joe biden's coming here to
help then amen that's good
you know but i'm very thankful for you
know the help that
donald trump did give you know with the
national guard and sending more law
enforcement here because it did it did
do something it did help i think what so
many people are attracted to donald
trump about is he meets a lot of fearful
needs
uh people want to feel protected they
want to feel in control
his leadership style his speaking style
i think definitely helps people
connect to that the democratic party
really tries to tap into a lot of the
relational side of things
as much as anything else joe biden's
presence here
is about profile and visibility there
has been
some concern and democratic ranks that
donald trump's aggressive
on the stump campaigning was giving him
a prominence
that was lacking in their man long after
both men have moved on
they'll carry the campaign issues laid
down here
in the race for the white house kenosha
will go the distance
james matthews sky news in kenosha
wisconsin